les voyagistes du canada mise sur la
nature sauvage laventure les aurores
boréales pour attirer les touristes
étrangers
les aurores boréales pourtant ne sont
pas menacées elles par le tsunami
touristique qui devrait frapper en 2017
le canada le panorama est tellement beau
ça nous donne la chance de voir des
choses que nous verrions pas autrement
on lève le drapeau jaune on questionne
parcs canada l'agencé arqana 2 pour
savoir fillon clan pour faire face à
cette affluence n'obtient pas des
impacts négatifs le lors difficile titre
en 50ème anniversaire de cette
initiative le d'amener davantage de
jeunes ont par alain ruscio et le
directeur général de snap québec la
société pour la nature et les parcs des
premières choses qui parle ici une
augmentation de la circulation
automobile et donc la probabilité
qu'elles aient des contacts et des
impacts des collisions avec la forme
c'est déjà documentés j'ai déjà envie ce
genre de chose au togo d'iliad il ya des
solutions 5 qui pourraient être mises de
l'avant
augmenter le nombre de navettes ses
favoris certains transports en commun
pour s'assurer d'une part qui est moins
véhicules mais aussi pour rendre
l'expérience des visiteurs plus agréable
les gens qui se présentent à la guérite
qui attendent une heure ou deux heures
pourrait accéder ou parce que ça rend la
journée un peu difficile jeunes gens
pensent aux gens qui ont fait des
randonnées
il pourrait y avoir des gens qui sont
plus impatients qu'ils veulent est allé
un peu plus vite qui contourne et qui ne
respectent les règles mais des mesures
de surveillance en amont principe de
précaution pour avoir des jeunes
éducateurs s'assurer que si
effectivement on détecte qu'une agence
qui atteint un certain niveau a déjà un
impact négatif on contrôle des moyens de
limiter ou rediriger des gens verte au
tac le fiel elle est entre temps par
canadiens consultent de la population
lancée la semaine dernière ce qu'elle
considère être la plus grande
consultation de son histoire sur le site
internet parlons de parcs canada était
si bon que ça tombe sur cette année
l'occident le mandat de parcs canada
paul fort à chaque deux ans mais
justement
la faillite du 150e du canada c'est
vraiment une belle occasion puisque tout
le monde en parle
nathalie fille et directrice des
relations avec les médias chez parcs
canada fait là on pense vraiment qu'on
va avoir beaucoup de monde qui
s'intéresse à nous on le sait mais c'est
ça nous avons nous sommes très contentes
que le monde s'intéresse à nous au
canada les fêtes c'est ce nom sait pas
c'est un peu par hasard mais je dirais
c'est le moment idéal de le faire
c'est tellement d'attention sur lui puis
on est reconnus ou à l'échelle mondiale
de faire bien soin de notre programme de
protection de l'intégrité écologique et
l'a connue comme on attend un des
meilleurs dans tout les services de part
comment est dia guerre et directeur de
l'expérience du visiteur chez parcs
canada pour le 150e une des choses qu'on
va faire beaucoup de choses pour assurer
que les canadiens quand et harry que
sont bien informés qu'ils peuvent bien
planifier leur visite les visiteurs qui
arrivent bien préparées bling bien
planifiée ils vont savoir comment ce que
la meilleure façon de vous aiderez cette
place donc ils vont profiter de leur
expérience et aussi vont pas nuire à
l'écologie de la place ou de l'intégrité
commémorative de la place papillon ayant
les formations qui ont les moyens de
bien une visite et l'organisation des
nations unies a décrété 2010 est l'année
du tourisme durable
le canada pourrait donc bien être la
terre pour tester tout à faire cette
année faire la preuve que c'est possible
ou que c'est impossible
sur la piste des solutions durables pour
le tourisme dans nos parcs
on découvre par exemple programme appelé
sans transcanada qui est appliquée au
parc provincial de quoi tiko en ontario
mais ici on est dans le grand nord de
l'ontario à l'écart des grands
mouvements de migration des touristes
ont la même michel savoy et gestionnaire
du programme sans trace canada ou en
anglais vont user world in ce programme
et plantes les pierres tous les pièges
naturels
on les respecte la vie sauvage
évidemment on a bien la faune à la
distance on veut pas s'approcher trop
proche des animaux sauvages et
finalement et spect les autres usagers
respectueux envers les autres visiteurs
dans n'importe quelle partie toutes les
entreprises de toute aventure respectent
ces normes essaie de ramasser les
déchets de protéger l'environnement et
pour que les prochaines générations ne
s'enfarge pas dans des tas de déchets à
chaque fois qu'ils vont visiter un site
marcel frayssinous est propriétaire de
l'entreprise touristique à laâyoune
adventures basée à whitehorse au yukon
et fois c'est contraignant comme par
exemple à toute une procédure avec l'eau
grise a drama saissac grain de riz pour
pas laisser de traces ils sont surpris
et puis après ils comprennent et se
disent oui c'est vrai il ya cinquante
personnes qui laissent à ksour une
poignée grainerie la fin de l'année à la
fin de la saison
normalement les gens ils y sont déjà
conscients de ça la plupart sur tout ce
qui vient de faire des activités de
plein air raid
d'efforts alors c'est assez facile de
les convaincre de ça parce qu'ils
comprennent qu'il faut il faut ramasser
et à laisser derrière soi
un reportage de radio canada
international